- For a castle straight
out of a fairytale,
look no further than
the Alcázar of Segovia.
(playful music)
Located in Central Spain, the
Alcázar of Segovia is one of
the country's most visited
and distinctive landmarks.
Built in the 12th century, the Alcázar has
served many functions over the years.
A fortress, a royal
palace, a state prison,
an artillery college, and most recently,
a museum and military archive.
However, it's most famous
function could arguably be
that it served as an inspiration
in some of the most iconic Disney films.
The similarities between
Segovia and “Cinderella”
can be found in the
buildings brick facade,
turrets, and location, perched high above
the neighboring countryside.
Walt Disney also went
on the reproduce Segovia
as the Queen's castle in “Snow White,”
with it appearing in the film
in it's almost exact form.
If you can make it up more than 150 stairs
to the top of the tower,
you will be rewarded
with stunning views fit for a queen.